I want to get this right so I want to
look at my notes for this according to
this you are black that is correct
not african-american that's not a term I
like you how come you don't like the
term I'm ridiculous I was born and
raised in America I've never been to
Africa why am I an African American most
of my people have been here longer than
most of all the other people in this
room yet most people don't have a - you
know I'm an italian-american Greek
American Romanian American it's an
absurd term it's a term that Jesse
Jackson is almost single-handedly
crammed down the throats of our media
and after Jackson began to talk about
why blacks should have some connection
to Africa all of a sudden New York Times
LA Times all of the media began using
that expression
oculis yeah I mean I personally don't
use the term African American that much
because one time I had a guest on the
show and I referred to her as African
American she said well I'm actually
Jamaican so you know you mean so I guess
that that goes to your point and I
remember reading one time Dave somebody
was given a description of some suspect
who had done some crime was running away
and he was described as an African
American how do you know where he was
from Goodman from Africa coming from
Jamaica from Canada so what do you make
of that when someone like cuz I know you
really rail against Jesse Jackson and
these guys on the left that use and I
want to talk a lot about identity
politics okay so the guys that use these
phrases what what are they going for
there well they're whatare goal that the
goal is to tell black people that were
victims that discrimination and racism
remain major problems in America when in
fact they don't and they want black
people to vote for the Democratic Party
the Democratic Party gets ninety five
percent of the black vote and the reason
they get it is because blacks are
convinced that the number one issue
facing the country right now is social
justice racist white cops discrimination
systemic racism microaggression whatever
a new word they come up with and it's a
bunch of nonsense a number one problem
domestically faced in this country is a
breakdown of the family and President
Obama said it I didn't a black kid or
kid not just a black kid a kid raised
without a dad is five times more likely
to be poor and commit crimes nine times
more likely to drop out of school and 20
times more like it
end up in jail so you're far more likely
to end up in jail without helping a dad
than you are because of a white racist
cop right so but you wouldn't not
acknowledge that there are some systemic
issues give me an example tell me what
you think the most endemic racist issue
is what is it well I would say that
because black people in most cases in
many cases were descendants of slaves
that racism as a as an institution that
is just 2000 a certain amount of it just
exists I 2050 give me the most blatant
racist example you can come up with
right now I think you could probably
find evidence that in general cops are
that cops are more willing to shoot if
the perpetrator is black what's your
date of end white what's your basis for
saying that last year though look I know
a lot of people would say look what's
going on I know what they would say
talking about what the facts are 965
people were shot by cops last last year
and killed 4% of them were white cops
shooting unarmed blacks in in Chicago in
2011 21 people were shot and killed by
cops in 2015 there were seven in Chicago
which is a third black a third white and
third Hispanic 70% of the homicides are
black on black about 40 per month almost
500 in the per year last year in Chicago
and 75% of them are unsolved where is
the black lives matter on that the idea
that a racist white cop and shooting
unarmed black people is apparel to black
people is BS it's complete and total BS
and and the reason for these so-called
activists saying this is the assumption
that racism remains a major problem in
America the media CNN especially MSNBC
runs down whenever a black cop shoots
somebody and and it's some some march on
Washington it's ridiculous
black people half the homicides in this
country are committed by and against
black people last year there were 14,000
homicides not talking about suicides are
talking about homicides half of them
were black 96% of them black on black of
that 7,000 wears a black black lives
matter people on that so that there's
where you would say that this is purely
because of social justice this you're
purely because they want ultimately for
people to be angry enough to just keep
voting Democrat that's right and where's
where's the evidence of the lack of
social
justise when a black suspect is killed
by a cop
believe me the media is on it people are
watching it and and justice will will
for the most part occur in Baltimore
where Freddie gray was killed Freddie
gray died in a van I shouldn't say was
killed died in a van yeah you have a
city that's 45% black city council is
100% Democrat the majority of City
Council is black the top cop at the time
was was black the number-two cop with
blacks the majority of the command staff
is black the the mayor is black the AG
is black and yet here we are talking
about racism I mean it's it's absurd
yeah third so it's funny I find myself
caught in-between this a little bit as a
liberal where I want to always try to
defend the other so in this case the
other being black people I'm always
sympathetic to that and they yeah yeah
at the same time I hear you laying out a
pretty solid well just the facts I say
something else too there was just a
study University of Washington and it
turns out cops were more reluctant more
hesitant to pull the trigger against the
black black suspect than a white suspect
probably because of the fear of being
accused of racially profiling and the
fear that the civil rights established
was going to come down on him so if
anything whites are more likely to be
shot by a cop under certain
circumstances than a than a black person
and in last 30 or 40 years the number of
percentage of suspects killed by cops
who are black has declined 75% however
the percentage of whites killed by cops
has flatlined yeah and so if anything
people are more concerned about shooting
black people for fear that they're gonna
be called racist and almost all every
one of these incidents whether it's Eric
Gardner in in New York who died because
he was selling loosies and resisted
arrest
whether it's Tamir rice in Cleveland who
it was twirling around the gun whether
it's Michael Brown in Ferguson who had
just committed an strong-arm robbery
almost every one of these incidents
involves somebody resisting arrest why
don't you just do what the police tell
you my dad said when I get pulled over
have my hand at 10 o'clock have my hand
at 2 o'clock say yes sir say no sir make
sure my paperwork is in order and if I
feel the cop is mistreating me get a
badge number and deal with it later on
if Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton and
Obama and the whole
group of them told black people to do
that we'd have a lot fewer of these
things to deal with in the first place
yeah all right so I'm with ya I'm
hearing a lot of what you're saying in
here so as a black conservative then who
now you've you've laid out your case
there but you haven't laid out yours I
asked you to name the most important
example of racism and you gave white
cops going after black people and I and
I told you gave you the facts for that
so that's nonsense so what you must have
something else what else is it if you
think racism remains a problem in
America give it to well I think it
remains a problem not it every time it
may not be systemic in that we have it's
not like you're not being hired because
you're black there's no systemic reason
you no legal reason that that exists
that kind of thing but I think that
racism as a general I need theory I need
I need some specifics you gave me the
white cop thing what else give me
another example what you think is a
problem well well as a black
conservative tell me how to know you how
do you get people to come around you're
the one who made the assertion that yeah
racism remains a major problem in
America I asked you to give me an
example you gave me white cops going
after blacks I as far as I'm concerned
you didn't hold it up very well what's
the other argument you have what's the
other thing well I don't know that it's
systemic in that in the sort of macro
I'm not I don't know what it is you're
talking no no I'm not getting into
school BS that we have a race we have
affirmative action so a black person
with a with an SAT and a GPA of X will
get into a school faster and easier than
the right person with an SAT or a GPA of
X and if going to going to school is a
route to the middle class you can make
an argument that blacks have an easier
route the middle to the middle class if
you're talking about blacks about
poverty the poorer you are the more
accessible loans and grants are for you
the the problem the biggest burden that
black people have in my opinion again is
the percentage of blacks 75% of them
that are raised without fathers and that
has every other social negative
consequences connected to it crime not
being able to compete economically in
the country being more likely to be
arrested that's the number one problem
facing the black community and when I
hear people tell me about systemic
racism or unconscious racism I always
say
give me an example and almost nobody can
do it so so the family stuff I'll follow
your logic there I mean family stuff
what what can actually be done about
that then I mean what because that's a
big reverse to welfare state in 1890
1900 you look at census reports a black
kid believe it or not was slightly more
likely to be born to a nuclear intact
family than a white kid even during
slavery a black kid was more likely to
be born under a roof with his biological
mother and biological father than today
what's happened is we launched this
so-called war on poverty in the 60s
we're literally Lyndon Johnson sent
people walk knocking on doors and I
lived in the 60s and people knocked on
doors uprising women of their
availability to welfare provided there
was no man in the house
and we went from 25% of blacks being
born outside of wedlock in 65 to 75%
right now and you look at how much money
that we spent on welfare and the lines
are parallel
it was a neutron bomb dropped on this
country not just in the black community
but on people in general at one time
only about 5% of whites were born
outside of wedlock now 25% of whites are
born outside of wedlock I was in college
in 1970 and there was a report called
the Moynihan report the Negro family a
case for national actions written by a
liberal by a man who became a Democratic
senator for the from New York and at the
time 25% of black kids were born outside
of wedlock he said my god this number is
is horrific if we don't do something
about it it could get even higher well
fast forward 25% a white kids are now
born outside of wedlock it is the number
one problem in this country and what
we've done in my opinion is we
economically incentivize women to marry
the government we've allowed men to
abandon their financial and more
responsibility and now we have this
Saudi using the left has done this right
ok so do you think then that as a black
conservative that the biggest issue is
it's impossible to have this
conversation right like the stuff we're
talking about right now is rarely really
discussed in the media you know people
you've written some books about it and
people talk about it every now and again
but we rarely have this discussion
because and this is where I will agree
with you that the left has made language
such a problem and everyone's so trigger
warranted safe space that were afraid
that if you have this conversation that
somehow I'm going to come
racist you know you know that's not well
we don't have the conversation we don't
have the conversation because the left
would then have to look in the mirror
and go jesus H Christ
look look at what I've done and they
don't want to do this I've had a radio
show for almost 25 years I've invited
Jesse Jackson on 50 times 60 times I've
invited our sharpen on that that number
Maxine Waters another loudmouth black
woman around here who's running around
talking about racism she won't come on
my show either they don't want to deal
with these issues why let's have a
conversation if I'm wrong tell me I'm
wrong tell me how I'm wrong
give me your data give me your facts
tell me what you got yeah and I could
quote the the Brookings Institution
which is a liberal think tank and the
Heritage Foundation which the
conservative think tank and they'll both
tell you that there's a relationship
between crime and bad schools and going
to prison and not having a dad so this
is not just a liberal kind of thing or a
conservative kind of thing it's a real
world kind of thing and they don't want
to have that conversation I've never
heard a reporter asked Obama about the
connection between the rise of the of
the single-parent household and the rise
of welfare spending I've never heard
anybody asking that question
not one time yeah and so as far as I'm
concerned is this is this desire not to
have this conversation for fear that it
then will cause you to rethink your
assumptions a psychologist will call
that cognitive dissonance the this this
anxiety that you feel when you have had
your assumptions challenged and you
don't want to do it it's uncomfortable
yeah so how then would someone like you
or someone that believes in what the
things that you're talking about how do
you wrestle away a little bit of the
narrative from the black lives matter
folks because obviously I tell the truth
they're about the same thing course I do
I care I tell the truth I talk about the
number one cause of preventable death
for young white man is car accidents the
number one cause of preventable death
for young black men is homicide
committed by other young black men I
tell the truth I give the facts and the
facts are racist yes take facts are
racist right so you know I'm friends
with another black conservative David
Webb you probably know on Sirius XM and
he's a Fox News contributor
and I had been doing a progressive show
a while back and I was on with someone
and they didn't know him personally nor
knew that I was friends with him right
and they kept saying he's the token
black eye on Fah right now I'm sure you
get plenty oh my goodness token boot
licker Uncle Tom
[ __ ] [ __ ] Tom coconut as in brown on
the outside right on the inside
Oreo same concept the Antichrist and you
got because they've got to malign
somebody like me I am a bigger threat to
their whole ideology than almost anybody
else a black guy who does not believe
that he's a victim a black guy who
believes in hard work and personal
responsibility a black guy who doesn't
believe in handouts a black guy doesn't
believe in the welfare state a black guy
he doesn't believe in affirmative action
I am the antithesis of everything they
stand for and therefore I can't just be
dealt with with facts and and rebut it
with facts I've got to be maligned I've
got to be a castaway I've got to be
treated as as if I'm Darth Vader that's
what the left does so that's interesting
and again this is where I've really
struggled with my guys on the left
because in a way that is actually
showing it's racist of course it is
three right because I don't have the
same right to have an opinion of
somebody else I've never heard rush
limbaugh be called anti white because he
criticizes Hillary on the left but I
criticize black left people and I'm and
I'm anti black it's bigotry it's racism
calling somebody an Uncle Tom is as
offensive as calling somebody an n-word
lover yeah so when it comes to to the
black community and politics so I got
you on a bunch of a bunch of this stuff
the black media in a lot of ways isn't
for some of the things that the
Democratic Party is for right because
the black community a lot of times and
it has a lot to do with the church is
it's more socially conservative the only
thing that that connects black people to
the Democratic Party in my opinion is
this notion of social justice and this
notion that racism remains a major
problem in America look down the list of
things that black people like ins and
support blacks are more pro-life than
whites are blacks were more anti gay
marriage then the whites were that's one
of the reasons it's proposition passed
here in California is because of the way
blacks and browns voted again I didn't
vote that way but it's the way a lot of
blacks and browns did
Black's want to be wealthy when the
reason Donald Trump is getting about 25%
of black which is five times by the way
the the percentage that Mitt Romney got
is because of Donald Trump's swagger and
his and his being proud that he's made
money and so and and in the inner city
wait that's really fascinating little
piece right there one more quick
important the Democratic Party is
completely beholden to the teachers
union and vice versa the Union is
adamantly opposed to vouchers where the
money follows the kid rather than the
other way around
inner-city black women and fathers
inner-city black brown women and brown
fathers want vouchers they realize the
schools suck I went to Crenshaw High
School in South Central
right now three percent that's not a
typo three percent of kids can do math
at grade level I'm gonna send my kid to
that school
because I don't have enough money to
send my kid to a better school it's it's
it's an assault there's a program called
the DC hope scholarship program where
every year parents who subscribe to them
to the program and and it's four times
as many people want to get in as there
are seats will give kids about ten to
twelve thousand dollars to go to a non
DC government school and every two years
when it's over Obama the Democrats kind
of try to shut it down and the reason
they don't is a bunch of black parents
go to the streets have a press
conference start crying and so all my
kids doing better I can't think of
anything more damaging to a kid's future
is to send him to a school where it's a
[ __ ] School where the kids are are not
learning where a lot of them are not
learning because they don't care and
where the whole level is now dumbed down
to cater to that lowest common
denominator in a class and as a result
you have kids that have poorer SAT
scores and the otherwise would if they
had a chance to go somewhere else that
challenged them and so inner-city
parents want vouchers young black people
when they're told about the benefits of
privatizing Social Security want to do
it because 65 years old blacks die
sooner than whites do and when you die
all your contributions to Social
Security go poof as opposed to being
able to will it too
child when blacks are taught about this
young blacks want the opportunity to put
their money into a account that they can
control so when they get 65 years old
they have real money so privatizing
Social Security vouchers abortion
same-sex marriage all of these issues
blacks are really not in lockstep with a
Democratic Party but the Democratic
Party has successfully convinced blacks
that racism this white cop this is why
it's spread demands out to get you and
vote for us and we'll deal with it so
how much of this is a messaging problem
if I grant you all of that right how
much of this is just a messaging problem
by the Republicans because it seems to
me and I've said this several times but
someone like Tim Scott who is a black
Republican senator right from the south
right he should be a hero not only of
the black community but he should really
be a hero of the left right because this
is a successful well I should be an
American Hero he really should be I mean
he should some certainly alley at the
very least be bigger in the national
debate why isn't he a bigger surrogate
for whoever he's gonna support I assume
it will be a Republican why is this guy
lost in in this scheme well it's the
same reason that black states vote 95%
for the Democratic Party he's considered
to be an Uncle Tom he's a Republican
he's a black Republican he said he's a
he's some sort of unicorn I don't know
what he is that that's how that's how
they feel so then what do you do what do
you do as a Republican to break this
narrative you know I got it you told the
truth I got it you tell the truth but
obviously there has to be something
bigger than messaging here because well
you're telling me the numbers 90 95 it's
an uphill fight I mean to me there is a
access of indoctrination you have the
media you have academia and you have
Hollywood all of which tell black people
that they're victims most professors are
to the left the media certainly is off
to the left and Hollywood's to the left
and so you get up and and you're
indoctrinated all the time with things
like social justice inequality the man's
out to get you we need a higher minimum
wage you name the left-wing a policy and
and and you and you pick it up through
osmosis that's why when we first started
the conversation I said I hope to move
you towards the center and you say I
hope to move you towards towards the
towards the center and I said it's not
going to happen because
because I'm I there's nothing you can
tell me I haven't heard but I probably
can say some things your audience hasn't
heard because LA Times New York Times
CNN ABC NBC CBS New York Times you name
it these are all to the left whatever
left-wing position you're gonna hear it
you're gonna hear why how and where but
but the other position you won't hear
unless you watch Fox News or listen to
talk radio and a lot of people won't do
it if you make them if you pay them
right so I hope it's clear in our 40
minutes or so together so far when I say
I'm on the left I consider myself a
classic liberal and that I stand for
liberal principles John afterward
male-type liberal exactly exactly that's
not a liberal and and I know in a lot of
ways that that makes you a concern
you're a Jack Kennedy kind of kind of
Democrat he cut taxes right he was a
cold warrior he will he liked hunting he
liked the Second Amendment so doesn't
this show you how stupid the words are
so what I did at the top of the show
shows you how the Democratic Party has
evolved to the left and abandoned
principles my mom was a was a Democrat
my mom was a Republican my dad was
Republican all his life and my mom
stopped voting for the Democratic Party
and she said as many people have said I
didn't leave the Democratic Party they
left me she didn't like welfare she
didn't like the idea of rewarding people
just because you had a kid and then
giving you more money when had an
additional kid she didn't like any of
all of that right and she started voting
for george w bush her last two election
cycles so it's really ironic that's not
messaging it's the fact that the country
and the country in general has gone to
the left and the Democrats to the to a
greater degree the Republicans have gone
to the left the country has changed in
part in my opinion because of
immigration including illegal
immigration people who are coming to the
country illegally from third-world
countries like Mexico they don't know
what I'm talking about when I talk about
limited government they believe health
care is a right they're taught that in
Mexico they're taught that other places
and they come here in America and they
pull that lever for the Democratic Party
which is why in my opinion the left
wants what borders to be porous because
it changes the country page of the
electorate
it changes the demographics the
Democratic Party has not won the white
vote since 1964 the more white people
there are in the country the worst
Democrats do the more left-wing the more
people of color there are in the country
the best the left does and so what
incentive is there for them to to
suborders what incentive is there for
them to shut down sanctuary cities to
stop catch and release there isn't in my
opinion there's been a very subtle and
very diabolical changing of the
mentality of this country by left-wing
people so that a state like California
could never vote for Ronald Reagan as
they did in the past could never vote
for Richard Nixon as he did in the past
you have New York and California just
write them off
and there's 10 or 12 states now that we
fight over everything else is now
written off it's ridiculous